Good morning YouTube. Professor Jang
here with another uh video.
Now, some of you in the comment section
have been asking me why World War II has
not started, why the conflict between
the United States and Iran has abaded.
The answer is because modern warfare
is hybrid warfare. 9% of warfare you
will not see. So much of warfare
nowadays is informational controlling
the media narrative, electronic cyber
warfare, psychological weakening the
will of the people to fight you and
cover ops uh economic sabotage uh
imposing sanctions trying to assassinate
the leaders of Iran. So the United
States and Israel are committed to a
policy of regime change in
Iran. Ideally they would like to
assassinate the Ayatollah Kami because
that would trigger a secession crisis in
um Iran.
Right now their main strategy is is to
decrease the legitimacy
of the regime in Iran. And the best way
to do that is to
um decrease the capacity of the state to
deliver basic services
for example water. So what's happening
in Tran right now a city of 10 million
is there's a water s shortage
um because of heat because economic
sanctions because of overpopulation
tan is having problems ensuring water
supply to its people. you you can bet
good money that the Israelis and
Americans will take advantage of that to
engage in economic sabotage. Basically
trying to destroy as much of um Iran's
critical water infrastructure as
possible. Uh they would want to
basically create a famine, a drought. Um
now the irony of that is that by
engaging in this economic sabotage
the Iranian the Iranian people will
develop a greater resolve to resist.
And once the resolve, once the will to
fight has been increased to a certain
level, then the Iranian government can
close off the straight of Humus, which
would compel an American ground
invasion. And if if America were to do
that, America would send in ground
troops. And as I've said in multiple
videos before, the American military
would lose this war. Okay? Okay. So,
that's how I see the war developing over
the next uh few months.
Today, I want to talk about what the
future's going to look like next 10 20
years. I want to take everything we've
learned so far and combine it into a
grand thesis about how the world will
develop. And the argument I want to make
to you today is that esquetology
drives geopolitics. And to make this
argument, I'm going to ask three
questions. First question is why are
esquetologies so compelling? Second
question is what are the major
esquetological
uh traditions and how do they converge
together? And the third um question is
based on these convergence points, what
can we predict about the future? Right?
So let's look at the first question
which is why are why are esquetologies
so compelling? And as I've said before,
esquetologists are compelling because
they are narratives that capture the
human imagination. They answer three
fundamental questions. Where do we come
from? What are we doing here? Where are
we going? It's a complete story on to
itself. You can think of esquetologies
as scripts really scripts that have a
momentum of their own. Scripts that
allow for unconscious coordination,
scripts that present roles for
individuals to audition for. So just by
participating in a script, you are
helping the estology progress forward.
Okay. And to understand why
esquetologies are so powerful, please
remember the universal law of game
theory. Um, in a previous video, I
discussed
how people win in a game. And the
formula that tells us who wins a game is
mass times energy times coronation.
As I also said in that video,
conspiracies,
there are plenty of conspiracies, but
they're not they're not that effective.
Uh because it's very hard to maintain
secrecy. You can't maintain possible
deniability.
And because everyone has an ego, it's
hard to maintain uh cooperation because
everyone's fighting for his or her best
uh self-interest.
but with an unconscious coordination
which is what an esquetology provides.
Uh that allows for uh secrecy, possible
deniability
and um frictionless cooperation. And
that's why esquetologist are so
powerful.
Now some of you may hear this and think
this doesn't make any sense because it's
really individual self-interest that
motivates us. And what's really
important to understand is these things
esquetologies and individual
self-interests are not in conflict with
each other. In fact, they reinforce each
other. Now, in school, you may be taught
that to succeed in life, you have to
work hard, you have to be talented, you
have to get uh good grades in school,
and you have to be very intelligent.
Certainly, that's what I believed. And
it took me 20, 30 years to recognize I
was wrong. It's not what you know, it's
who you know.
to succeed to succeed in life you have
to be able to work with others
uh in an secretive unconscious co
coordinated manner in order to achieve
certain uh goals
um and that's what esquetology provides.
So when you describe to esquetology when
you commit to an esquetology others will
help you achieve
wealth and power. Okay. So that's why um
esquetologies are so compelling and so
powerful. Not only are not only do they
capture our imagination and inspire us
to collective action and sacrifice, they
also benefit us materially. Okay. So now
let's move on to second second question
which is what are the major
esquetological traditions out there and
how do they converge?
So uh before I go into uh the six major
traditions um I I want to remind
everyone of three caveats. The first
caveat is that within each religion
esquetology is only a minority extreme
view. Okay. Only a small minority of
religious devotees will actually believe
in the esquetology. That's the first
caveat.
The second caveat is that there's
tremendous diversity within each
esquetology. You can interpret the
esquetolo es esquetology allegorically
which is say like it's compelling you to
a path of personal redemption and
salvation in order to improve the world.
Or you can interpret it literally which
is that this is this is a true prophecy
and everything in it will happen in
order for the world to end or for the
world to become a better place. Okay.
And also
there are different sequencing of events
and different interpretations in the
esquetology. Okay. So that's the second
caveat. Esquetologies within each
tradition are very diverse.
And the third caveat is that
esquetologies are dynamic. And the
reason why is esquetologies are are in
conflict are in competition in
communication with different
esquetologies. Think of esquetologies
as stories that are trying to be the
best possible story in order to capture
the imagination of their believers. And
to do that, they're going to incorporate
the best elements from different
esquetologies
um into their own. And that's why so
many of these esquetologies, they follow
similar pattern because they've been
learning uh and adapting um from each
other. Okay. So having said these three
caveats, let's go into the six uh major
escalological traditions. And I'm going
to focus on the most extreme version of
each tradition because according to game
theory, it's the fanatics who matter.
It's the fanatics who are the most
energetic, who most committed to
achieving
um the esquetology. So the first
esquetology is Zoroastrianism which was
the original esquetology. In the
Zorastrian tradition
there's the world is divided into good
and evil. Um the light and the darkness,
the truth and the lie. And at the end of
the days there'll be a final battle
between these two cosmic forces. And as
humans, we must choose which side to
fight for. At the end at at the end of
this uh battle when good has triumphed,
there'll be a day of judgment. Okay? And
this structure, this cosmology heavily
influenced
uh Judaism.
And so in the Judeic tradition uh
because Jews have been persecuted for um
thousands of years
they believe that eventually a Messiah
of war will come to them and he will
lead the Jews to victory against all the
enemies. He will reconstitute the nation
of Israel and bring back all the Jews
from the diaspora. He will build the
third temple and he will usher in the
masonic age of peace, prosperity,
truth, justice. Okay, that's the Judeaic
tradition. The Judeic tradition went on
to influence the Christian Zionist or
the Protestant tradition. Okay, so uh
the pro protestants believe that the
Messiah is Jesus and he's already come.
So in order to usher in his second
coming certain conditions have to be
met. First condition is the nation of
Israel has to be reconstituted and it
was in 1948. Um
then the third temple has to be built
and there has to be a war uh of Gog and
Magog. The antichrist has to appear. And
once these conditions are met, then to
save his people, Jesus will descend from
heaven on a cloud, destroy all his
enemies, and usher in a millennium of
peace,
truth, and justice before the final
judgment. When Jesus returns, there will
be a rapture where all Christians will
immediately ascend to heaven. So that's
the Christian Zionist Protestant
tradition. Um and again this is the most
extreme form of that tradition.
Then you have the Islamic uh tradition
which is based both on the Judeaic and
the Christian tradition and it's very
similar. Um so the Muslims believe that
after an age of tribulation when the
world has turned its back on God when
the world is divided
um a great leader will come to unify the
people and lead the people uh to victory
in the war of Gog and Magog. uh Gog and
Magog is interpreted as the antichrist
and Gog and Magog can be interpreted as
maybe western civilization for its
materialism but it could also be a
certain force. So for example maybe uh
the city of London.
Um
so that's tradition. Then you have the
Orthodox tradition which is what we we
talked about in the last video. The
orthodox tradition believes that Moscow
is a third Rome. It has a destiny to
restore the Basian Empire and to achieve
this destiny uh Moscow will fight a war
with Turkey. It will destroy Turkey and
then res return the Greeks to
consenapole thus restoring the Bajin
Empire and thus unifying the Orthodox
Christian world. Now what's really
interesting is that there is a
geopolitical theorist named Axen Dugan
who's turned this esquetology into a
master plan for Vladimir Putin to
implement. If you don't know who Axen
Dugan is, you have to um watch his
interviews. You have to read his books
because he's probably the most important
geo strategic thinker we have today. I'm
going to put his videos and his books in
the description below. So please make
sure you spend the time to actually
research him because so much of what he
says helps us understand the world as it
is today and how the world will develop
over time. So in 1997 uh Dugan published
a book called foundations of geopolitics
where he describes his master plan for
how um Moscow can restore the basin
empire. So
what he understands is that for the
longest time
whoever controls the seas controls the
world because most trade was done
through sea. But in a time of nation
states, in a time of railways,
um if one power can unite the Europe and
Asian continents into the Eurasian
continent, then that power can negate
sea power and uh become the global
hedgeimon. And and that's why the
British the British Empire are committed
to two things. The first thing they're
committed to is maintaining naval power.
The second thing they're committed to is
ensuring that no major power would arise
in the Eurasian heartland. And that's
why um the British basically provoked
Germany into World War I because Germany
was threatening to be this power and and
that's why uh Britain is now afraid of
Russia because Russia is trying to be
that power to unify the entire Eurasian
heartland. for Dugan. Um to unify the
Eurasian heartland
uh what what Moscow needs to do is first
of all create the Berlin Moscow access
to reconcile itself with Europe. It must
also create the Moscow Tokyo access to
reach out to um uh Southeast Asia and
also to create the Moscow terrain access
uh to control the resources of the
Middle East. And by building this
alliance, what Moscow is doing is not
only not only restoring the Bison
Empire, but it's also restoring the Pax
Mangalaka, the Mongol Empire. So Moscow
see itself as the um heers to both the
Basin Empire as well as the Mongolian
Empire.
Now um Duran thinks this is entirely
possible because uh the Iranians, the
Japanese and the Germans all feel
slighted um humiliated by the
Anglo-American Empire. So if you give
them a choice between sticking with the
Anglo-American Empire or joining the new
Russian Confederation where they'll be
giving more freedom then they will opt
for the Russian Confederation. So that's
the grand plan. Now obviously the
Anglo-American Empire is going to oppose
this uh plan. And so for Dugan, what's
important is to create internal chaos
and descent and conflict within America
and within Britain to destroy the
Anglo-American Empire. And that's
already happening right now because um
you have Brexit in Britain and now you
have this mass immigration which is
threatening the British identity in
America. You have Donald Trump who is
proposing America first. So all is going
to plan. This plan also recognizes that
both Turkey and China are also enemies
to the rise of this um Eurasian uh
unification.
Um but as we discussed in the previous
video, Turkey itself is not very stable.
It's kept together uh for the political
maneuvering of Eragon. Once he's gone,
then all these ethnic tensions,
these geopolitical tensions, these
economic tensions that exist in Turkey
will explode and it will overwhelm
Turkey, thus causing it to collapse um
as a nation state. It will lose its
coherence as a nation state. Dubin is
not worried about China as well. He
understands that Russia and China can
never be allies uh because China is too
economic dependent on the Anglo-American
Empire. Basically the point is Russia
has nothing to offer China. China it's
basically a manufacturing economy which
must sell its goods to the
Anglo-American Empire. Russia will
cannot absorb these goods. Um at the
same time there are a lot of internal
contradictions in China. I can tell you
as someone who lives in China for many
many decades, China is not going to
survive an economic catastrophe. It's
not going to survive an e ecological
catastrophe. In fact, its economy is uh
propelling its the the nation to a
ecological catastrophe.
China is overpop populated, has very
little resources and it imports onethird
of its food. It imports most of its oil.
These vonnet industries, EV, uh AI,
uh rare minerals, they're all
contributing to massive ecological
destruction in China. I mean you can say
it's unsustainable but you can also say
these economic policies that um destroy
the environment it's really suicidal.
Okay. So so China does not have a very
bright future ahead of it. So Dan is not
worried about China either. Okay. So
um that is the master plan of um
Alexander Dugan and again it is based on
the Orthodox extology which perceives
Moscow as a third Rome and perceives
Vladimir Putin as a lazar as this great
unifier of the world of the world. Um in
Dugan's terms Putin is the
catacon. Okay, the catacon is Greek word
meaning the force that restrains the
antichrist. Okay, so for Dugan um Moscow
has responsibility to be the force for
civilization for good for God.
Okay, now let's move on to the last
esquetological tradition which is the
Catholic esquetology.
Now it's interesting because
um if you read Augustine and the city of
God, what he argues is that
the church is the millennium. Um the
church is the embodiment of the mezzanic
age. So with the coming of the church,
the world has ended because the church
is able to step out of history and
ensure peace, truth, and justice in the
world. And that very much is still the
um
official Catholic church line. Um there
are esqueological elements to
um the Catholic Church. For example, uh
Catholics do believe that there'll be a
second coming of Jesus. And there'll be
some certain signs that precede the
coming of the second coming of Jesus
which include the mass conversion of
Jews which include the age of
tribulation which include the coming of
the antichrist. But for the most part,
the um Catholic Church is committed to a
policy of personal esquetology, which
argues that it is for our own personal
transformation, our own personal
salvation, redemption, uh through the
guidance of the church that allows for a
better world.
This is the official line, but we can we
can be suspicious that this is actually
what they really believe. Um I'm sure
that there are certain elements within
the Catholic Church who who do have an
esquetological
uh worldview. Okay. And there are three
reasons why I would think the church uh
many elements in the church um want
radical global transformation. Okay. So
let's let's look at these three three
reasons. First of all, we have to
remember the origins of the Catholic
Church. It started out as a secret con
conspiracy against against the Roman
Empire and it succeeded. Okay. So the
Catholic Church is very good at
conspiracies. In fact, it really
developed the world's first intelligence
agency, first global intelligence agent
agency. Um there are certain elements
within the Catholic Church, the Jesuits,
Opusai which are which are famous for
their effectiveness, the organization.
um their um strategy. Okay. So, uh
that's the first thing we have we we
have to remember about the Catholic
Church. They are very good at
conspiracies. In fact, they're so good
we don't even talk about
uh their conspiracies. So, if you go
online on Twitter, on social media,
everyone's talking about uh the deep
state, everyone's talking about the
Jews, everyone's talking about uh the
city of London, but no one's talking
about the Catholic Church. That's really
weird. You have books and books and
books of all of of how uh Jews have
influenced history, but very few books
on how the Catholic Church influenced
history. I would think that um the most
powerful, wealthiest,
and most secretive organization in human
history for the past 2,000 years, they
would would have a much greater impact
on human history than the Jews. Okay.
So, the second thing to remember about
the Catholic Church is before the
Anglo-American Empire,
they were the empire. Okay? They had
they had a thousand years from the fall
of Rome until uh the rise of the uh
British Empire when they were in charge
when they were the de facto power in the
world. And for many they believe that
was the messianic age that was the
millennium that was the most perfect age
most growing age in human history. And
we screwed it up. Uh we threw it away uh
with with the rise of the British
Empire. And therefore we uh must return
to that golden age when the Catholic
Church was the dominant empire in the
world.
And um the um third thing to reme
remember the Catholic Church is
they really are the most powerful
non-state organization in the whole
world. They have a global network. They
have 1 billion followers.
If there is a global catastrophe,
they are the most ready to rebuild the
world after it collapses. So these are
major advantages for the Catholic Church
and that's why I think that um there are
many elements within the Catholic Church
who
do have an escathological
worldview. They have a plan to conquer
the world and they are slowly
implemented. Okay. So, having said that,
let's go over the major opposition, the
opponents of the Catholic Church. Well,
the first major opponent of course is
the AngloAmerican
Empire. And the Anglo-American Empire
represents of course enlightenment
principles, uh, neoliberalism,
uh, materialism, capitalism,
Protestantism. Okay? And, and remember,
the Protestants and Catholics hate each
other. Um, these are the two greatest
rivals in human history. Their wars have
cost millions of lives. Okay, so that's
the first major opponent to the Catholic
empire that the Cath that sorry that the
Catholic Church must destroy. Okay, the
Anglo-American Empire. Second opponent
is the nation state. Um so in
Augustine's formulation, the church is
outside of history. It is above history.
It controls history. Um but with the
French revolution
um
the idea of a nation state came into
being and the idea of a nation state is
that it is above church okay and that's
why in France there's such an emphasis
on separation of church and state so um
obviously the Catholic church wants to
reverse this order and in order to
reverse this order it really has to
destroy the concept of the nation state
okay and the third major opponent um is
really modernity itself the cult of the
individual ual uh which celebrates
materialism, hedenism,
pleasure,
um multiculturalism. Okay. So the church
needs to destroy
u all three forces if it is to resume
the millennium.
Um and we can suspect that there's
already a plan in place and the Catholic
Church stands a very good chance of
achieving its estology. Um, so let's
look at the three signs that the
Catholic Church is has a plan in motion.
Well, the current vice president of the
United States, JD Vance, he is a recent
Catholic convert. The new pope is an
American. Okay, I don't think these are
coincidences. Um, I think this is much
this is all part of a uh larger uh plan.
We also have to remember that the
Catholic Church is embedded into the
institution of power in the United
States. So, six of the nine Supreme
Court justices are Catholic. Okay. Um,
also the CIA was founded with the help
of the Vatican. So William Dunovan who
was the founder of the OSS the the
precursor to the CIA he was a Catholic
who was very good friends with the pope
also when the CIA came into being it it
had a mandate to fight communism around
the world the problem is uh the problem
was that at that time the CI didn't have
a global network the Vatican did have a
global intelligence network and so the
CIA and the Vatican formed a holy
alliance against communism and um there
have been so many CIA directors who are
Catholic that the CIA has been nicknamed
Catholics in action or the Catholic
intelligence agency. Okay. So, uh the
Vatican and the CIA are very very close.
Um another sign is that the Catholic
religion is growing very very fast in
America. Right now it's about 22% of the
American population. But all those
immigrants that are coming to America,
half of them are Catholic. And these are
the legal immigrants. We're not counting
the illegal immigrants who are majority
Catholic. And also remember, Catholics
um have more children than Protestant
families. So um the demographic trend
looks very good for
the Catholic um faith. But we can also
argue that if there's American civil
war, a second civil war, and the
institutions of authority are destroyed,
the American Catholics are in the best
position to capture an American state.
And if they are able to capture the
American state, then they would control
the world. Okay? So, um I think there
are some fanatics within the Catholic
Church who want to initiate a second
American civil war.
because they believe that um this war
will create the opportunity for the
Catholic Church to control America and
thus destroy all three of its major
opponents, the Anglo-American Empire,
the nation state and modernity
uh itself. Okay. Um so having looked at
the major esquetological traditions, I'm
going to discuss where they converge.
And what's really interesting is there's
actually quite a few convergence points
that are very important. The first
convergence point is that there will be
a major conflict in the Middle East that
will uh suck in the whole world. It will
be World War II. Okay. Second
convergence point is that America will
not be involved in this war. And that's
very interesting because America is
right now the global hedgeimon. So why
America isn't involved in this war, we
don't know. It could be because they
launched a ground invasion of Iran, it
failed and they were forced to retreat.
It could be the civil war going on in
America. Okay, but America is not
involved in this war. The third
convergence point is that China is not
involved in this war either. And I
suspect that it's because China is
facing an ecological catastrophe. It
doesn't have enough water. It doesn't
have enough food. doesn't it doesn't
have um um enough resources for its
people and you have internal descent
throughout the nation. It's China's is
having a hard time keeping itself
together.
Um the fourth convergence point is
that
the is that the antichrist will emerge
and different traditions understand the
antichrist differently. Um but they all
believe that this powerful force will
emerge who is charismatic and who will
unify the the the world.
Another convergence point is that um
Israel become the dominant power in the
Middle East presumably after America
leaves the Middle East and we can
understand why because America leaves
the Middle East then all of America's
military infrastructure sencom will
merge with the greater Israel project
thus creating the Israel empire. Another
convergence point is that um anti-mitism
anti-semitism will will grow around the
world compelling Jews to return to
Israel. Another uh another uh
convergence point is that the Dome of
the Rock will be destroyed and thus uh
provoking the Muslim world to take arms
against Israel and possibly uh
initiating the war of Gog and Magog. Um
another convergence point is the age of
tribul tribulation when the world will
face economic ecological uh geopolitical
catastrophe after catastrophe after
catastrophe when people's faith will be
tested when the antichrist will emerge
to deceive people into believing
um false prophecies into believing magic
into believing superstitions in into
denying the authority of God and of the
church. Okay, so these are the major
convergence points. So this so now let's
go on to question number three. Based on
these convergence points, what can we
predict about the future? So based on
all this, I'm going to paint you a
picture um of the future and what it
looks like. And um some of these will
not work out, some of these will work
out, but it's it's an interesting
framework for us to think about how
geopolitics might
um develop over the next 10 to 20 years.
Okay. So
um the United States launched a ground
invasion of Iran. Iran is supported
heavily by Russia. United States after a
few years of fighting, they give up and
they retreat. Um, and so the American
Empire uh retreats back into the western
continent. But this triggers a civil war
in um in America.
In Ukraine,
NATO decides Odessa will be the last
dead. So
Russia encircles Odesta and lay siege to
it. All NATO is brought in to defend
Odesta. This is the very last stand. And
um France, Britain, Romania, Poland, um
all the NATO countries are brought in.
Turkey is brought in as well.
And it's a stalemate. This war is going
nowhere. But
the Europeans don't understand why
they're fighting this war. The European
people revolt. And this causes civil war
in France, in Britain. It caused a
political upheaval in Germany. It causes
a political revolution in Turkey. And
after these civil wars and these
revolutions, Europe becomes more
pro-Russian, allowing for reconciliation
between Putin and Europe. Turkey is
destroyed in this process. Um Putin
allows the Greeks to return to
Castanopole, restoring the Bison Empire
and thus unifying the Orthodox world.
After the United States um leaves the
Middle East, the Greater Israel project
becomes the Empire of Israel.
The Empire of Israel in order to restore
the Davidic Kingdom. In order to usher
in the messianic age, they destroy the
Dome of the Rock to build the third
temple.
This causes antitism to explode
throughout the world, thus compelling
Jews to uh return to Israel.
The entire Islamic world wants vengeance
against Israel, but their leadership,
their political elite have been
co-opted, compromised by the
Anglo-American Empire and by the Israeli
empire. And so this forces revolutions
uh and civil conflict in around the
Islamic world. And now people are
begging for the magdi to return. The mag
the magny is um their world unifier.
Um at this point there are certain
elements within the Islamic world who
see Putin as the great savior. Um and in
the Islamic esquetology the name for uh
Putin is Dao
Kanan which is the same concept as the
orthodox idea of the catacon. Okay. The
one who stops antichrist from emerging.
And so Putin will init initiate uh
reconciliation between Islamic world and
the orthodox world. there'll be an
alliance between the Orthodox and the
Islamic world
and at this point um Putin can now seek
reconciliation between the Islamic
Empire so the Islamic world and the
Israeli empire. He can also seek uh
reconciliation between the Orthodox
world and the Catholic world and thus
unifying the world uh under him. Okay.
So this is the framework of the world
for the next 10 20 years.
Now do I think this will actually
happen? Do do I actually think that
Putin will replace the Anglo-American
Empire?
Um he thinks he will succeed, but I
don't think he will succeed. And the
reason why is because he's human. Um and
once he dies, then
civil conflict will rise within this
Grand Alliance. And um this civil
conflict will lead to catastrophe after
catastrophe after catastrophe. It will
be the age of tribulation. Um many many
people will die in this age of
tribulation. So the the outlook for
humanity is not that great. And this is
no different from what happened in about
650 uh 600 common era when Muhammad was
this great charismatic figure who were
supposed to unite all the supposedly
unite the entire world and he would have
if he lived another 10 years.
Unfortunately he died and this created
um uh civil conflict within the Muslim
world.
Okay. So those are my predictions. Okay.
And again the thesis the grand um idea
is esquetology drives geopolitics. So if
things happen the way they do then it's
because of esquetology and that gives us
proof compelling proof that it's really
esquetology that drives uh geopolitics.
So we'll see what happens next 10 20
years. Now having said that all all this
um I have to say it's not I mean it's
not secret what I'm saying it's not it's
not a great secret I've uncovered I mean
if you read a Dugan he lays out this
plan coherently in his interviews and in
his books. So then the question then is
given that this is public domain
knowledge, why doesn't the
Anglo-American Empire respond
strategically
to this? Why doesn't the Anglo-American
Empire have counter measures and counter
strategies? Why isn't the Anglo-American
Empire intent on its own
self-preservation?
And the answer is because the people who
control the Anglo-American Empire today
don't care because be dead in 10, 20, 30
years time. All they want to do until
they die is enjoy their life. And they
don't care what the world what will
happen to the world after their death.
These people of course are called the
baby boomers. They're the one to control
all the political power, the financial
power, the um um influential power in
America, the cultural power in America
and in the West today. And that's why
the West is dying. Okay. So, I'm going
to talk about this topic in my next
video. So, um I look forward to seeing
everyone then. Um
um if you're interested uh please join
my Discord server. I'm going to put the
link below. If you have the means,
please support my work by um donating
donating to me on buy me a coffee. I
really appreciate all the donations. Um
it's it's real validation of my work.
Okay. All right. So, thank you so much
and I will see everyone next week.